hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at [ __ ]
boys 3 I've been doing a lot of leveling
off camera that you totally probably
wanted to see a whole bunch of it was
really boring and grindy and I know how
much you appreciate when I get boring
and grindy Oh Oh anyway stop for another
shot so let's get to it in my skull shot
of death Liberty blah blee bloo blah
blah bloobity blah bloop here's to me
and you cling keys oh hell that one went
down the wrong way
oh dear nup oh dude up whoa okay that is
one way to start the day was during
episode I like Todd started out really
relaxed and calm and I enjoyed it very
much for what was going on either way
okay now that we took care or no oh no
we didn't take care of foxy that's right
we don't have an item for body around
why did I think that Roy cuz I'm getting
a little tipsy top see and after this
shot I probably gonna get along at South
Sea uh okay so what I need to do is I
need to I need to I mean I love 'old up
to level 18 so I could probably take on
mangle her shadow mangle I just want to
make sure there's nothing else for me to
have outside of that because I mean
frankly it's gonna be a rather long
fight and a rather difficult fight that
but I don't know if I should or if I
shouldn't should I stay or should I go
should I try to get more I mean I have a
lot of items I have a lot of items I
mean I didn't use my items as
appropriately as I should I should have
used fortification in defense a bit more
than I did before I just need to play a
bit safer when I'm fighting mangle I
think I could probably do it I don't
know if I did I spend all no I didn't
spend all my tokens so I could probably
do a little better but I mean yeah
alright you know let's go for I think I
could do it like I did quite a number on
it before so I'm pretty sure why didn't
do quite a number but I was damaging him
so I'm I level up like three times
and I know the recommends probably 20 oh
I'm really good
I got good I followed Cranky's advice
and I went to Donkey Kong land and I got
good so I'm gonna get good I'm gonna go
beat him in his face or something
sorry soughing it was a weird bird
flying over here did I or whatever hi
mango I got your esoteric sex device oh
you want to be hip like the cool kids
I'll show you how to be cool yeah okay
so yeah yeah yeah what what we're we
just bear with whoa what where did that
come from
repeat power I didn't know I had repeat
power oh that's because I leveled up and
I learn new abilities and therefore the
new abilities would have turned into
stuff that I can actually use in terms
of items so I really was going into at a
disadvantage so I might actually be able
to do this alright so first I'm gonna
I'm gonna use the sleep powder because
the sleep powder actually puts him to
sleep so that I wouldn't have to worry
about him wait ham let me make sure I
got that on the right one cuz I wasn't
looking okay sleep powder and now I
should be able to take care of these
a-holes
and actually finish them off okay damn
why'd you have to hit me first
why are you gonna be so rude wait you
gotta beat so as I don't know how long
he's gonna stay asleep but it's good
that he's asleep and frankly I'm okay
with this as long as I don't
accidentally hit him Oh oh no that kind
of hurt maybe I need to get my health
back up before I fight mangle because
mangle is gonna freak my steez BAM okay
I'll be back this is gonna take a while
I'll obviously talk if something
significant is happening yes yes I'm
doing it okay he's no longer paralyzed I
need to paralyze him again I'm gonna run
out of these repeat powers but I want to
use them like right now because one nine
hundred God if I don't go there's so
much damage not okay dude that's not
okay I'm gonna take this mobile to get
my health back up to a normal level they
didn't even give me like the help that I
need to get back up to a place where I'd
be safe it's just uh
bunch of malarkey Oh what I probably
should do instead of like wasting the
stun on healing myself I should put him
to sleep well I don't need to do it now
so I'm almost up to full and I repeat
power and Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam okay so
he's unable to move right now so ice
take advantage of this hit him hard with
my own two feet
okay okay no longer paralyzed so I need
to he's gonna hit me so ice prize
sleeper right no don't don't scream
prepare for the big impact okay alright
come on
ah come on
I almost had him I was gone and good the
bad that the booth on top all right let
me do this yeah cuz then I'll
refortified eula fine I'll be good okay
this is perfect it's delicious life--all
I know what no AG I know okay now that I
have my a G up I should still be ahead
of him so I can restart Oh No
oh I was close one hahaha okay so he's
paralyzed for two turns at least you
should be able to hit him hit him okay
he's unable to move but after this one
he's going to be very able to move so I
need to sleep powder him and then he'll
back up Wow oh no need for that I'm too
good for you oh god it feels so good to
be a gangster feel so good we against ya
Hey it feels still good to be a gangster
I feel so good to be a bit of power imma
be nice messing up ah come on cooperate
with a beanie beat a beanie sorry about
that
don't know why I put you through that
endeavor I've been drinkin okay so I won
reach level 19 dispel dance okay that's
good so I'm actually ahead of the game
because this recommend level way
get a little angry there give little
upset things bad happening to you but
now I gotta have a new balloon boy and a
boy all you have to do is I'm probably
have to farm up a bit more anyway
admirers yet take a mango no good I'm
better I got a secret report okay so now
I can learn phantom fold
what does that mean and my learning
ability is from his learned ability from
chica probably my healing ability I do
have a healing ability now but not that
I've had a chance to use it because he
took away all my abilities one of the
locks on the office door dropped to the
ground with a Clank okay cool so a flush
oh come on of course I don't know why I
forgot about the puppet of course the
puppets gonna be here because the
puppets always here to the party it's
not a party without the pump it's not a
party without the puppy participating if
the puppet Varda peter-puffer feet the
packet pick up uh from people popping
the packet people pass already a
douchenozzle button much we're yep buddy
we're yeah where you gonna be at mister
aww oh there you is and this time like
in this playthrough I'm actually gonna
try to beat the puppet but I know the
puppets gonna be a son-of-a-bitch and
hard to beat but like in the last ones I
got like advantages because I got all
the best items like right off the bat
and they were like too good so hopefully
I'm gonna be able to do I don't know why
I'm doing this what am i doing what am i
doing what am I know where am i God
where we go
so the new puppet is in a level-4 area
lucky Sodor honey I ain't wanted the
lucky who the sorting hat don't look so
good he looks a little sickly now but
I'm gonna ease his pain if you don't
hate me
you don't know what I mean however I'm
gonna see what this does because it
means I connect a wire tomb so it might
like stun him or something Oh forgot I
got the puppet I forgot about the puppet
damn and damnit him I'm gonna try twice
oh that hurt but not that bad
holy crap oh that is good okay what I
mean also I thought it would do more why
didn't it do more oh boy us right I
didn't have enough for a second
ah sonic swing Wow
jeez hurt real bad actually oh crap I'm
gonna die oh crap I'm gonna die why am I
gonna die listen this isn't the thing
this wasn't supposed to happen this way
oh well sue focus on [ __ ] that
didn't matter then I wasted a turn which
is just delightful I'm so happy about
that I'm so happy about that
I can't believe there's a thing
we got this we got this oh crib baby
crib oh baby a triple maybe okay come on
that didn't do anything to me I'm a
robot I may have a dead man inside me
but I'm a robot
god damn you don't know anything what
you're doing
give me a balloon more I learned
devastation didn't I already know
devastation pretty sure I already knew
devastation that was the thing that I
learned while ago whatever I hope I have
enough tokens for this I don't think I
spent all my tokens yeah all buyers you
look good okay Wow Jesus that's awesome
though that's a lot of damage I have
enough tokens what does it matter to me
I got plenty of tokens and what's with
these like these are a shield made out
of a [ __ ] pizza seriously that's why
it does so little it's like one the
world is even the point that that like
does nothing for me okay I got it
actually what I should probably do after
this is I should probably start farming
on the UH other things but before I do
that I must see if he finally takes a
blanket now because I got the poster I
have oh that's right I have the secret
report too but I have the poster that
says officially licensed ready [ __ ] boy
merchandise maybe there's like another
poster I could punch off the wall and I
could like form it all into a blanket
that he would enjoy and then again maybe
not maybe I'm just a dumb dumb and no
one's gonna cooperate with me but for
now I'm gonna read this yeah let's do
this
just read this paper I'm so ready I'm
devoting this section of my thesis to
explaining the various incarnations of
the aforementioned traveller in these
many alternate timelines
following on from my research and my
first report I have concluded that this
is the path the traveler followed the
first instance of the traveller asked
into a new timeline and goes to great
interference they aim to take the place
of the past self but they didn't realize
they'd slipped in to set new timeline
upon killing their alternate myself they
attempted to reenact their plan however
a rift asked over the timeline rewrote
the events of the future it was as if he
had never existed at all their
counterpart from this timeline would
never have the chance to live through
the events that ultimately would decide
the travelers view of the world and the
poor choices they made because of it the
original instance of the travelers
seemed to have mysteriously disappeared
after the killing had occurred however I
believe that they crossed into a
different timeline perhaps I'm not
positive by the way I don't know these
people
this timeline was free of corruption
free of the mistakes made by them
ourselves many time over this is where I
have lost track of them I do not think
they are dead however
the second incarnation of the driver
were followed the same path as the first
and up until they crossed into the new
timeline thanks to the meddling that the
initial incarnation had caused this
traveler was able to freely execute
their master plans unlike the prior
version however they didn't enigmatic Li
vanish my theory is that they were
instead destroyed by a devastating blow
to the very core of their mortal soul as
for the last incarnation this is the one
who the initial incarnation disposed of
he's not relevant to my research and as
the kids these days would say [ __ ]
slugs this is the extent of my knowledge
on the subject but I'm continuing my
research every day until next time I
don't know what any of that mean well
the professor good news okay so now that
we read that note all dramatically Allam
whatever the hell I was trying to do now
what I need to do is I need to find out
how in the Frick frakking world I can
get Roxy to frickin master Vayne why is
that why does it have to be my primary
goal why do I absolutely intentionally
going like oh come on just jack it
already
just get a big Jo session going I mean
come on what are you waiting for I mean
come on right
I forgot about the puppet the whole time
I was reading that I kind of okay so
what about ado is I'm gonna fight up
some of these level three party hats and
I'm gonna see how it goes with them
because I haven't fought one yet but I'm
still I'm pretty sure I'm gonna be
totally fine alright whatever just die
already oh god you're so wimpy
oh you're so
P oh I'm so strong why did I even bother
with that god I'm so great God look at
me
level 20 already good for that okay so
that's good I guess I'm learning like so
many skills like where I don't have a
lot of allies I have an exorbitant
amount of skills okay so anyway I got to
fight these guys until I get to having
the the new thingamabob err the part of
the key that they have because if I want
to assemble all the key parts I'm just
gonna need to fight these guys until I
do it I mean one of my goals could be I
could fight up all of the hacks and just
try to get in a situation where I could
actually beat him and get the key their
key shard what is it
gamma I have no idea I don't no idea I
don't know my Greek I was not in a
fraternity although like I did I like I
did like explore the idea of it among
fraternities are not for me not
discarding the anyone that Bennett of
eternity but I mean they do have a bad
reputation but some of them are decent I
guess I don't know people are people
some guys are [ __ ] some guys are not
some girls are [ __ ] some girls are
not and anyone in between can be any
sort of angel or demon that they choose
and believe it's just up to you to
decide who you're gonna be so out of our
garage and praise for the day and I
think I'm pretty much done with this
part so I'm gonna farm up a bit find the
items that I need to find and see you in
the next video I've totally screwed that
up I feel weird now that's odd word
awkward so I'm gonna do this again
everybody rare with me yeah thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video Bob
uh wait wait wait wait with a boom oh oh
oh yes I knew it had to be said the
poster blanket was made
foxy yes it is Franck you are genius a
semi a genius for getting you to the
point where you could do that
so our surprise surprise the last
episode didn't end oh yeah ah so gross
yes yes a mysterious portal okay so Fox
he's like I don't know if I see will be
the next one I think Foxy's the next one
that I need to fight but I need to level
up a lot more before I'm able to do that
so now I can actually do the the outro
in a way that's not totally absolutely
creepy as hell thank you everybody
someone for watching I hope you're
thoroughly enjoying this series thank
you for joining me on this adventure and
thanks for playing along and as always I
will see you
I need to do that
I didn't
I'm the king